Prime Minister Benjamin Netanyahu's main election challenger, the Blue and White party,...
...conceded defeat in Israel's general election.
In Belgium, Prime Minister Theresa May...
...insists she wants Britain to leave the European Union "as soon as possible,"...
...as she arrives at a Brussels summit to ask fellow leaders to delay Brexit.
Fighting for control of Libya's capital escalated as eastern forces led by General Khalifa Haftar...
...clashed with UN and government-backed troops on the outskirts of Tripoli,...
...forcing thousands of residents to flee.
In the US, President Donald Trump says he has yet to see the full report...
...drawn up by special prosecutor Robert Mueller...
...into his election campaign's allegedly suspicious links to Russia.
Finally from Albania, police and investigators are on the scene at the Albanian capital's airport...
...after a Hollywood-style robbery on its runway that left one gunman dead...
...while his accomplices fled with millions of euros.